dangerous category 5 hurricane is moving
towards the Hawaiian Islands it could
have a devastating impact chief weather
caster Lonnie Quinn of our New York
station WCBS is tracking the threat
Lonnie good morning thank you John and
good morning everybody well this is what
Lane is looking like real well-defined I
have that storm let me give you the
latest information the winds are at 160
miles per hour it's a cat5 ok this is
new information moving to the west at 9
miles per hour
it is right now from Kona Hawaii and the
Big Island 385 miles you got to think
about this that makes this storm the
closest cat5 to ever get to the island
of hawaii a hurricane landfall in the
hawaiian islands overall they are just
incredibly rare I mean hardly ever
happened there have only been two other
hurricanes that have made a landfall in
Hawaii and there was those were any Qian
dot if you take a look at the forecast
cone how this is forecast to move it's
gonna turn to the northwest and then
sort of parallels the island as of right
now the eastern islands are no longer in
that cone of concern the western islands
continued to be in the cone but I want
to give you a timeline because this is
going to get a little weaker as it
pushes closer to the islands so it looks
like the effects will be felt anytime
from say Thursday later in the day until
Saturday morning this is a Rainmaker all
right a foot of rain very possible up to
two feet even possible in the Big Island
winds 45 miles per hour sustained gusts
are 75 miles per hour so as of right now
beyond it looks like the hurricane-force
winds stay offshore but that is subject
to change Lonnie I know you will be
following this closely thank you